this is all animation really what you're
kidding
relax everybody i'm here so i had the
opportunity to work on the lego movie i
know they actually started looking at
lego pieces under microscopes
so this was the hardest shot i've ever
done in my career you just dropped a
bomb right there
thanks to noon for sponsoring this video
stick around to figure out how you can
get your free new evaluation
hey everybody welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artists react
we are joined today on the couch by matt
demiro who is a longtime industry vet
he's worked on a ton of films you've
heard of he's currently an animation
supervisor over at agura studios matt
can you tell us a little bit about
yourself hi i'm matt i am a
as you said i'm a supervisor for agora
studio my career spans now more than 20
years i've worked at frame store animal
logic in australia and ilm and now agora
what is agora studios so gora studio is
not your typical studio where there's an
infrastructure and all that we're
actually a virtual studio and we have
hundreds of artists all over the world
we primarily do animation and and
rigging and this way we can kind of
cater to almost any production from all
over the world which is great because
we'll have supervisors that are located
everywhere also friggin we got the
hebarro himself here
well it's actually one of three
hemorrhoids we were three supervisors
working on uh kibaro is just a wonderful
show alberto mielgo it's his own story
he directed art directed he is behind
every little corner of that project so
now this is the second time we're
looking at this episode
yeah now we actually actually worked on
it
we were lucky enough to supervise the
animation and do all of the rigging for
the show so we took care of that portion
of it and it was just a phenomenal
experience was this show motion capture
is this all hand animation this is all
animation that is what you're kidding
that is a very important question did
you at least have like reference surely
for her at least you have an actual
dancer performing
the routine the choreography you're
correct i mean i mean sick
so alberto is very meticulous also it's
all in his head and it's rare that you
get the opportunity to work with
somebody that has the whole thing in
their heads they filmed these amazing
performers they had multiple cameras
front side and essentially we got that
footage and we use that for all the
performances and with alberto he will
film until he gets the performance that
he wants so these performers like worked
really really hard and he finally got
exactly what he wanted and the mandate
was anything weird you keep
don't go beyond that don't go less than
that
and some people argue well you're just
rotoscoping at this point and that's the
big debate why didn't you mocap this
actually we had one or two artists go
why don't we just look at this but i
think there's a jitteriness to human
beings that gets translated into mocap
that somehow gets a bit removed when
you're when you're animating it i do
think it adds a certain level of hyper
realism not hyper realism but it's like
art right like
there's something about it but it's not
quite perfect well i think it echoes
what the whole vibe and aesthetic of
this entire you know episode is it's
very painterly it's it's surreal almost
exactly that it feels hyper real but
also very much so not at the same time
and it's a very interesting combination
so i'm fascinated that like you have
this similar approach in the actual
animation itself and you can see in some
projects and even old-school disney
animation 2d stuff where they would like
like project on a wall and draw also the
feeling changes yeah i mean that's
that's i think there's a bigger gap
there
in terms of with what we do but
sometimes you'll watch a project you go
mocap not mocap mocap not mocap we've
done some motion capture work in the
studio as well and really at the end of
the day you end up with just like a
simple skeleton and real human beings
are very dexterous and like yeah like i
have a watch here right i have a watch
on well if we did mocap and a character
wanted to grab my wrist it's just gonna
it's gonna move over my wrist like if
you're doing animation it's gonna grab
my wrist you can have the fingers like
land around the watch when you're
dealing with the actual 3d model and
doing it by hand
[Music]
so this was the hardest shot i've ever
done in my career
you just dropped a bomb right there
the hardest shot of your entire career
yep yep what alberto likes to do is the
cameras at the very very end so
everything has to work in all these
views so this is why we have a profile
and this is how we approved
everything so everything had to match on
every angle but as you can see the male
performer does not have a giant armor
all the contacts and all that had to
work in every angle just because the
cameras might change i guess it lends
itself to doing hand animations that
you're dealing with the actual character
rig with the armor and the proportions
and now when you're moving everything
you can move it so it's perfect and
you're not like clipping through itself
you're not intersecting because you
might that might get revealed later that
means that's more work because typically
a shot like this starts and you already
have the camera angles already set so
you know what you can get away with like
you're not going to animate the dude's
toes and feet if it's a close-up on his
face
obviously correct but if you don't know
whether or not the shot's going to be
like oh look at these toes real quick
gotta make sure those toes are ready to
go
there was a point where we talked about
production we're like okay
can we ballpark saying no toes on this
one
but we'll give you the knees and i'll
work towards the end that's cool
he's very very savvy and understands
every department which is very rad for
somebody so creative i feel like that's
very important yes
the first time i saw anything from
hebaro was just an animated like gif and
my first reaction was like whoa is this
real
you know and it's funny because like
when you stop and you look at the actual
character models like they don't look
real they very much look like cg
character models like it's incredibly
high quality cg it's beautiful rendering
don't get me wrong but like it's cg but
yet there's so much of it that looks
real and like so much that comes through
the camera work and the imperfection and
the dirtiness and the you know shakes
and the dust and the light and the
physics is something you don't ever
really see in cg but you see it all the
time in real life it just triggers all
these things in your brain but oh that's
real the cameras add energy and life
and helps tell the story that he wants
and i think as animators someone's like
oh i really want to lower the hand
so there would be like a nicer
composition but in the end what what
often he would say is that if he were to
film an actor he wouldn't necessarily
know where the camera is and his hand
wouldn't be in frame that feels forced
and he wants it to feel real
and so by having things that are too
perfect in cameras you lose a bit of
that
so we're always talking about other
people's effects we're always talking
about other people's movies and you're
probably like what about you guys where
are your effects well we have been
trying to stay on the cutting edge of
technology you know that crazy led
screen for the mandalorian we've tried
to do the same thing here for our show
son of a dungeon
so by utilizing virtual reality trackers
from the vive
unreal engine 5 and its real-time
rendering and photo scanning to get our
environments from our game board rather
than having to model the whole thing
we've been able to crank out some crazy
shots and on top of that this year we
have fenner and jordan that have been
working with us and helping us out and
we've actually been using nuke you know
that crazy vfx program that they always
talk about in big budget films we're
actually using it i mean check out these
before and afters i think we have like
10 times as many vfx shots compared to
the first season and as cool as these
shots are it doesn't matter if the story
is no good but we actually have like a
full-length first episode for free it
just dropped on the channel actually it
just dropped like an hour ago you should
go check it out tell us what you think
it's been a year in the making and
nothing would mean more to us than if
you wouldn't watch it episode one it's
on youtube right now go check it out
you know when you talk about like
mimicking elements in real life to have
this weird surreal version of looking at
cg that feels real there's another
project that comes to mind
oh my gosh i love this song
[Music]
in the lego movie it's like they're real
legos it's animation land still but
they're real legos they have the seams
from the molds they have the bumps they
have the scratches you know spaceman has
his helmet broken like every single guy
had their helmet broken yeah so i had
the opportunity to work on the lego
movie what did you guys do to get that
feeling of real i know they actually
started looking at lego pieces under
microscopes
to see like what is it because i think
the first passes they had they're like
it doesn't there's something missing and
then they realized that some of the
bricks or most of the bricks had a small
amount of warping to it
and a small amount of scratches and and
those kinds of details
that they were then able to do a
procedural pass before lighting to to
warp the bricks a little bit so the
light can catch those imperfections and
actually look nicer so you guys built
like a fallen lego simulation inside
your system pretty much well i didn't
but some very smart people did it
when you look at it it's just a simple
smooth plastic surface but in reality
just like the mirrors at a house of
mirrors where it kind of like reflects
light very differently and it makes that
reflection look very different for
something like this that is still enough
to subtly influence our brains into
believing that this is real plastic
because we see it all the time without
actually acknowledging that it's not
perfectly flat i suppose you also see it
really represented when you have like
walls built out of bricks and it's not
like perfectly
like flush scenes coming together
becoming invisible it's like you
actually see a little bit of the gap and
like now you can see the individual
bricks like you could in real life
because they're not like you see it
there they're not perfectly squished all
down the same amount
one of the interesting things about the
mandate for the show was that imagine if
somebody was making this in their
basement the the typical reaction for an
animator is you wanna you wanna overlap
stuff and wait what
so if an object goes down typically
something will will overlap and come
down right like the springiness of
yellow if i'm doing this with my chest
and my head's bobbling this is this is
overlap essentially so a lot of
animators you know we want to add that
we want to add details this is we were
like oh this is a feature for lego this
is going to be amazing so the first
thing we wanted to do is overlap heads
and then as a lego piece you know we all
played with them as kids and as
grown-ups let's be honest um and then
you would kind of separate them and you
know kind of kind of swivel off those
two little pegs and you got it looks
kind of sweet and gives a little bit
overlap and this and that and then we'd
show it and they're like no
it feels like we're seeing their innards
oh we don't want to say that like oh
okay
and then the funny thing is as soon as
you kind of put them back together and
kept the same overall motion
they felt more appealing you took away
this and you made it very
motions and then the hand gestures like
those little cuppy hands
and it just became like
funnier one of the things i used to say
if you're not giggling at your desk
then something's going wrong
is it harder or easier to animate this
kind of stop-motion vibe uh it depends i
think certain artists have preferences
and some people maybe prefer the vfx
style the heavier creatures
i love animating twos you mentioned
animating on twos which is a old classic
example to get
fewer frames for more time right instead
of animating for every single frame
you're animating every other frame and
so you end up with a sequence that's
roughly like 12 frames per second type
deal so when you're doing the animation
for twos are you specifically stop
motion animating every two frames or do
you have like an animation that goes out
the whole time but only every other
frame is getting rendered so we had to
control every frame that were going to
be rendered typically we would block or
do the first pass of animation which is
a rougher pass and less detail to just
show oh this is what i want to do to
jump here and i want to land here and
kind of you know you rough out your your
idea
and you would do that spline meaning it
wouldn't be on twos it would be smooth
animation and then from there you go yep
all the ideas are good you know put that
on twos now i keep saying twos but for
this show they said if it's gonna be
threes if it's fours if it's ones you
guys can do whatever you want so long as
it makes it better yeah so i definitely
did notice superman there was on ones he
was floating very smoothly as everyone
else was like
so flight on twos doesn't look good
again it feels kind of jaggedy but like
maybe for an arm motion or something if
it's a really fast motion you go it has
it happens over three frames
i actually need a pose for the arm for
those three frames because if not it
just pops yeah it gets lost exactly i
mean lego movie is one of the most
beautiful cg movies in my opinion it
still holds up really well oh yeah they
nailed it it's going to hold up forever
it's not it's not like in 10 years but
it doesn't look like legos it's like no
it's still looks like photo real legos
no matter when you look at it
i got to supervise on this it was a
small team it's been one of my favorite
vfx shows that i've done we got to go in
in the pre-prod pre-pride you mean
pre-production correct pre-production
which means that you allocate time to
develop a look a style and a feel before
you actually start doing shot work and i
got to communicate directly with the
director and it was super fun because
also i think sometimes you just find
people that you're on the same
wavelength okay which is what happened
with the director and myself so i had a
great time working with him
what's lcg lcg wow
that slime layer man yeah it looks great
how do you approach a character like
this that isn't like a real creature
where you can't have reference
perspectives and body mechanics are very
important for me there's things you can
do you can film yourself kind of
crawling on your knuckles or and get
some of the you know interesting motion
you can find you know sometimes footage
of like athletes doing certain things
but i think for this i think we shot
some reference but obviously our weight
and our legs and all that don't
correlate properly to a character like
this
it's like what is your reference for
something like this do you look to
nature do you look to
animals you can but it's like hard to
find an animal that would have arms and
drag their bodies i think some of it is
also this is also where you get some
freedom a trained eye with saying okay
well it has to be a bit slower a bit
heavier there's there's bones in here so
the hips have to work a certain way with
the torso and you could potentially
compare that to a human and say okay or
or an animal that has a kind of like
kind of dog legs and see how the hips
work and there's stuff like that you can
pull and you can pick and choose for the
for the shot i think some of that is
actually when we do get to be more
creative and we do get to put some of
the you know like as the arm comes down
the elbow has to absorb the weight and
stuff like that which i think
communicates to the character feeling
like they're tangible
so what made this project so rewarding i
think it's the collaboration aspect
and on a lot of very very big projects
you get x amount of collaboration
also they shouldn't be on some of those
big projects you can't have a hundred
voices like for example there's a guy
getting his head ripped out
and like hi the director said i just
want this to be really violent i'm like
well could he have a hard time pulling
it for a bit and then finally it rips
and then you can have like
yeah there you go so being able to pitch
that directly to the director allows
some freedom and it's cool when they say
yes right to your ideas it feels great
how do you find this like boundary
between the director and yourself as an
artist where you want to bring your
creativity and you want to bring your
ideas and they also have their
creativity and their ideas as a
supervisor and even as a lead i think
it's important to have
your artist's voice
it'll be heard
and sometimes you'll get and i love i
love juniors or people that just started
the industry i love juniors because
they're so excited and anytime we need a
new idea those are the people i go
we need something to happen with this
and he's like oh what if and it's always
too crazy so you just drop it down i'm
like
30 you're like all right cool i'm gonna
pitch that okay cool
but i think it's important and everyone
then feels like they're a part of it and
i think that's also part of the roles
that we have as leads or soups to try to
engage people
what's up guys christian here taking a
break from the vj station that is behind
the camera on this react episode to come
tell you about my favorite sponsor of
this show noom noom has an emphasis on
science to help you meet and exceed your
non-scale goals where they kind of teach
you how the body works and how your mind
works and tries to kind of tailor a
program that works for overall long-term
weight loss journey one of my favorite
tools that they have is the food tracker
and they've actually updated it since
the last time we talked we used to talk
about green yellow and red foods but
they've learned from people like me that
red kind of makes it feel like you're
not allowed to touch those foods ever
again like red is no go and that is not
what noon is trying to teach you they
change the red to orange just to make it
more of a warning orange are foods that
you want to eat a little bit less of and
a little bit in moderation but that does
not mean swear those foods off forever
i went to hawaii just about a month ago
for like two weeks and you know you're
on vacation you're not going to abide by
your diet all the time you know you're
going to be out there trying the new
cuisine in the new place you're at so
sometimes the weight fluctuates and
that's okay again noom teaches you that
it's not all about the constant loss you
know you're going to have fluctuations
in weight and also in what you eat and
sometimes you're going to break your
calorie budget and that's what neum
tries to do is empower you through
knowledge so you can make good decisions
for yourself moving forward they have
great articles based on science and
focus groups to really help drive those
points ever since they came and
approached us i've been an avid user and
i have not stopped since and so it's
really helped i've really just felt
better and i've lost a lot of weight
even when i do fluctuate i feel good
about being able to get back on track
with their support so i can't recommend
it enough if you would like to get your
free new evaluation just click the link
in the description below and to get
started i saw all the comments and
people that have reached out over the
months with both words of encouragement
but also just comments saying that
they've given it a shot and they've
started noob and they're having a great
time and great success and that's like
the most motivation you guys could give
me ever thanks to noon for sponsoring
this video and approaching us again hit
me up let me know about your results or
that you got started and uh let's get
back to this react episode
so with a virtual studio where
everyone's spread out anywhere it feels
like you could probably create a pretty
big community so for the agora community
we're trying to create a space where we
can have high quality teaching and
lessons for artists that's for free
and this is coming from veterans like me
and other veterans and other people that
are from the community
that are working at large
and and sharing those insights and tips
and tricks
we also offer
mentoring at an affordable rate this
doesn't just mean for
uh
up and comers students and this and that
for any level any skill level is
actually quite great somebody wanting to
go from vfx to feature film and they're
like i don't know they can work on their
own piece get some mentoring by somebody
who's been doing it for a long time and
um that's actually quite cool okay we'll
have a link down the description below
if that sounds interesting to you it's
really cool that you guys are doing that
and honestly really smart because
right now with how much media is just
exploding everybody's like we need more
people that know how to do this but yeah
there's not enough people that know how
to do this yeah it is finding ways for
for the ones that do want to give back
to the community artists that are
working or find little pockets of time
for them to collaborate or to
to contribute and for the mentoring
stuff it's something that some of us do
on a day-to-day with the artist that we
work with and so it's just a natural
thing to do with
people that are trying to get better
cool matt thank you so much i really
appreciate it thank you this was awesome
yeah till next time yeah